hello everyone and welcome to two
incredible games from round six of this
year's Tata steel Masters and Tata steel
Challengers uh first game we're going to
show is Jordan v Forest versus gues from
the master section and then from the
Challenger section the game that you
guys most requested and after reviewing
it I definitely understand why it's
Mustafa ilmas versus Elena rubar uh
really a game so complicated that I'm
not I'm only going to show like 20% of
the lines that can be shown uh because
the video would be too long there are so
so many lines there but let's check out
this one first it's Jordan he has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 and he
had a tough start to the tournament he
did lose two games uh but then he uh
defeated the Women's World Champion J
and June he got two draws and now he
faces gues and gukesh also had two
back-to-back losses but then he defeated
Yan pish in the previous round you've
seen that brilliant brilliant game where
he found that tactical shot uh and well
the rest is history now let's check out
the game E4 E5 by gash Knight F3 Knight
to C6 and we have Pawn to D4 Jordan goes
for the scotch um game or the scotch
opening e captures on D4 we have Knight
captures and queen to
F6 uh putting pressure on the Knight
here so you could bring the Knight back
Knight to F3 Knight to B3 uh you could
even capture on C6 then we go into that
Bishop to C5 line you you guys know all
too well uh the but here we have Knight
to B3 it's a fairly rare move uh and now
after Queen to G6 putting pressure on G2
is sort of hindering the development of
the light Square Bishop Pawn to F3 also
the E4 Pawn is attacked so Pawn to F3
Bishop to D6 and now Knight to C3 and
here we have Knight G to E7 it looks
like black could capture the pawn on H2
but it's a it's a funny thing no you
can't if you capture Rook captures and
queen captures G3 with check seems like
white should resign but it's actually
white who is much better here because
after King to E2 okay you capture The
Rook Knight D5 what what what do you
play here okay the queen is defending
the C7 Pawn for the moment but Bishop to
F4 is coming and there's no good way to
stop Bishop to F4 so you're only good
choice is to move the king but now
Bishop to F4 will attack the queen for
example Queen to H4 Queen D2 and now
after whatever let's say Knight G D7 you
will just Capt on C7 The Rook goes back
you attack The Rook once again The Rook
goes back and I play Rook 8 A1 you will
you will put the king over to the queen
side you have all of your pieces
developed and black has a king that is
UN castled it's uh hard to get the Rook
into the game hard to get this Rook into
the game the bishop still is yet to be
developed so that's why you don't play
Bishop captur on H2 even though you know
for a Bull game or a Blitz game it does
look appealing it just doesn't work
Knight gt7 was played Pawn to F4 and now
Bishop to B4 uh pinning the Knight here
we have Pawn to F5 uh and now Queen to
F6 we have Bishop to D3 uh and the
position has been reached before in the
women's Grand Prix uh 2021 it was played
in in GI in jalar and in that game uh it
was Jans Abdu Malik versus antoneta
stefanova Bishop back to D6 was played
but here GES goes for Bishop captures on
C3 and it is now as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so okay he
will win a pawn we have Bishop captures
Queen captures Bishop to D2 and queen
back to F6 and now yordan just Castle so
he is down a PA but he has many pieces
in in the game and has still to develop
his pieces uh we have Pawn to D6 now
King to H1 a useful attacking move you
don't want to always be looking out for
that uh you know one check that ruins
your game uh Bishop to D7 at some point
the Knight will move and goar's Bishop
will take control of this diagonal uh
and now Pawn to A4 grabbing more space
on the queen side we have Knight to E5
attacking the bishop here and queen to
E1 uh Jordan would very much appreciate
it if gkes would just capture that
Bishop on D3 three I mean it's more like
a pawn than a bishop uh but of course
gkes will not do that he just continues
development Knight 7 to C6 Rook to B1
and now Pawn to A5 stopping further
advancement of the pawn and maybe you
can you know even at some point maybe
develop The Rook this way all in all a
useful decision plus you stop the pawn
on A4 where it can be a potential Target
for this bishop we have Knight to C1 uh
now comes Knight to B4 the B7 Pawn is
hanging so here gues defends it by
bringing the Knight to B4 and now of
course you don't want to capture the the
Knight here even if you could win a pawn
I mean you're giving up your dark Square
bishop and um you know staying in the
game with this light Square Bishop
that's that's a pawn and that's not the
way to play chess so here we have Queen
to G3 by yordan and now Pawn to H6 we
have Knight to E2 and bringing the
Knight to F4 or D4 we'll see what um GES
plays Now Pawn to G5 uh sort of asking
are are you interested in F captures and
G6 Al
and of course yordan is he wants to open
up the f file for his Rook we have Queen
captures offering a queen trade and now
can you trade Queens here well you could
but uh you're already down down a pawn
so you know trading Queens doesn't
really do all that much and the problem
is if you trade Queens you can't even
win that pawn on B4 for example Bishop
captures on B4 a captures and Rook
captures look at this Pawn to C5 attacks
the rook and once The Rook moves doesn't
really matter where Pawn to C4 traps
this bishop I mean it feels sad trapping
this bishop that's already trapped I
mean probably a pawn is stronger than
this bishop but yeah objectively it
would be winning for black so you don't
have this option you have to play
something else Queen to F2 by ordin H
and now gz just goes Knight B captures
on D3 we have C captures and Knight
captures on D3 which probably could have
been avoided if the queen was played on
E3 as now he does have to waste a move
Queen to D4 attacking the uh Knight and
the Rook on h8 uh but here just Rook to
G8 gkes solves all of his problems
because the threat of Checkmate is much
greater than the threat of losing a
piece so okay Knight to G3 and now gues
just brings the Knight back Knight to C5
while defending the B7 Pawn uh Pawn to
E5 okay the black king is still in the
center of course Jordan will go after it
Knight to E6 now attacking the queen
queen back to B2 and now Bishop to C6
and this is uh the strongest move in the
game probably and this is now the
strongest piece in the game defending
and E7 and becoming the the the you know
the absolute attacker here e captures on
D6 and now look at this beauty uh
queenside castles uh gues says I don't
care about captures or anything as long
as my Bishop is guarding B7 your queen
rook and the dark Square Bishop are
completely useless so here D captures on
C7 and just Rook to D4 bringing the Rook
into the attack also going after the A4
Pawn uh Rook to D3 was also possible
keeping the D4 Square available for the
Knight but Rook to D4 is also fine uh we
have Rook beat to C1 of course Jordan
would would very much enjoy eliminating
this bishop by Rook captures on C6 but
gukesh will not not allow it Rook to H4
and now if Jordan captures the bishop
look at this Rook captures Bishop now
comes Rook captures on H2 with check if
King captures then Queen captures with
check followed by Queen captures on G2
with Checkmate and if you don't capture
The Rook then The Rook forces you to
capture again will uh Queen captures on
G3 will come and if you play King to H1
now again Rook to H1 King to G1 and now
you get checkmated so that's the idea so
okay you can't capture the bishop right
away Rook to C3 was played and now
Knight to C5 again uh preventing the the
the capture of the bishop and uh maybe
even eyeing that A4 Pawn so okay Rook to
E3 getting the Rook out of Harm's Way
and now we have Rook captures on A4
since the bishop is now out of danger
but now Rook to F6 attacking the Queen
and again hoping to get that Rook
captures and C6 in h but now Queen to G7
pinning The Rook Now The Rook cannot
move okay Bishop to C3 again Jordan is
hoping to uh give up The Rook for the
light Square Bishop now comes Queen to
G5 going for The Rook here so now if you
capture the bishop here of course not
Pawn captures but first queen captures
on E3 so Queen to E2 adding a Defender
Here and Now Knight to E6 closing of the
E file for the for the Rooks and again
preventing Rook captures on C6 so it's a
it's a game where Jordan had a a light
Square Bishop that's basically a pawn
and gukesh has a light Square Bishop
that's uh you know worth more than any
other piece on the board uh and here we
have Rook to F5 attacking the queen and
going after that A5 Pawn as it is
attacked twice H but gukesh here has
such a brilliant tactical shot similar
to the one he did against Yan pishi in
the previous round uh feel free to pause
the video and try to spot this beauty
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh finding a
way to temporarily sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Bishop captures on
G2 with check and now the point is if
you capture the bishop uh then the
Knight cannot move you just take the
Rook on F5 and that's it white resigns
but if King to G1 as was played in the
game now look at this queen captures on
F5 a very nice temporary Queen sacrifice
uh of course the queen has to be
captured back Knight captures on F5 now
Bishop to F3 check winning the queen on
E2 uh brilliantly played by gues and
what's the end result of the combination
King to F2 Bishop captures on E2 Knight
to E7 with check winning The Rook on G8
but it doesn't matter King captures on
C7 Bishop to E5 also with check King to
B6 now Knight captures and G8 uh and now
just just the bishop to H5 getting the
the bishop to safety we have Knight
captures an H6 grabbing another Pawn H
but now just Knight to C5 King to G3 was
played we have Knight to E4 with check
uh King to F4 now Bishop to G6 and he
was in this position un move 45 that
Jordan F forz resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here gkes is
up two pawns and uh the Knight on e4 is
defended twice by the by the bishop and
The Rook uh which means that as Jordan
has a dark score Bishop the the the
Knight on a light Square cannot be
opposed which means that it's
Untouchable and H it's merely a matter
of moving the black king and advancing
those uh two connected pass pawns the
victory that's pretty much it there
there's no counterplay here from White
uh so yeah very nicely done by gesh
brilliant win against a very strong
player with the black pieces and this
means that okay as gkes lost two games
in a row now gesh wins two games in a
row and now the standings are Anish giri
on four and a half points followed by
Ala fuja who also won his game very
nicely on four points and then a bunch
of people on three and a half um prag
and three and a half gues and three and
a half abat on three and a half and the
Max vardam on three and a half who also
had a very nice Victory yesterday uh but
yeah that's uh uh what happened in this
round in the Masters but now let's check
out this wild wild game from the
Challenger section Mustafa ymas versus
elen rubar and Mustafa uh is playing a
incredible chess this is his highest
rating that he has ever had at 2665 as
of January 2024 he's a 31-year-old um
Turkish Grandmas so he is doing
incredibly well uh and Alina had a very
very difficult start to the tournament
she had four straight losses but then
she defeated Hans nean that the top seed
of the tournament former 2700 and now
she faces Mustafa so let's see what
happened in this one this game is so
complicated you guys will love it uh we
have Knight to F3 starting off with a
ready Knight to F6 C4 G6 Knight to C3
and Bishop to G7 transposing into the uh
King's Indian defense we have Pawn to D4
and castles now uh Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to D6 and now Bishop to E2 and pawn
to E5 so a very very standard stuff in
the king's Indian defense we have
castles uh and she goes for Pawn to B6
preparing to get to the light Square
Bishop uh Rook to E1 and now uh standard
here is e captures on D4 but she goes
for Knight to C6 first uh sort of to uh
invite D5 and it is now as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so
okay Mustafa says yes I will grab more
space of course in the center I'm
planning to play B4 so that works well
uh you know in the spirit of the king's
Indian defense Knight E7 and now Pawn to
B4 usually we say that uh uh against the
Queen's Indian against the king's Indian
defense white will have a minority
attack on the queen side whereas black
will try to create some sort of aing
King side attack on the king side uh
Pawn to A4 challenging the structure B
captures an A4 Rook captures on A4 and
now just Pawn to A4 controlling that B5
Square uh she goes back Rook to A8 and
now Knight to D2 F3 probably will be
played as you know that Elena will will
move the Knight and Advance this Pawn to
F5 again a pretty standard idea uh in
the king's Indian with Bishop to H6 sort
of hinting that if the B if the Knight
moves that the bishop will get traded
off so Mustafa keeps the Bishops on the
board we have Knight to E8 and now
Knight to B3 she strikes with Pawn to F5
e captures on F5 we have Knight captures
on F5 and now Bishop to D3 uh Knight to
F6 just bringing more pieces over to the
king side Knight to E4 offering a trade
of knights and while you could trade
Knights here Elena goes for Knight to H5
just putting more pieces in front of the
white king we have Rook to A3 The Rook
will later on be able to to help out
with the defense of the white king but
maybe even with the attack against the
black king and now Knight to H4 bringing
even more pieces in front of the white
king we have Bishop to F1 uh setting up
a defense here and now Bishop to
D7 uh putting pressure on that A4 pawn
and Mustafa plays Pawn to A5 just gets
rid of the weakness we have B captures
Knight captures uh and now Queen to E8
uh and here we have Pawn to C5 Queen to
E8 was a slight imprecision because now
Pawn to C5 is actually incredibly strong
for Mustafa but uh uh she she figures
out how to complicate uh the the Muddy
Waters even further here the problem
with the C5 is that if you capture D6 is
just winning there's no way to counter
this the move is so strong how do you
how do you react to this if C captures
on D6 you will play Knight captures on
D6 and um that's just all all the is to
it you can't really uh you you can move
the queen but then Rook will capture on
E5 this diagonal will open up the bishop
comes to C4 this diagonal is already
open the black king simply will not
survive in such an open position but
look at this elen plays Queen to F7 and
the position is winning for Mustafa now
but only if he finds a very very correct
idea here uh even without pausing the
video can you can you see the idea uh
Mustafa played the the move fairly
quickly uh he played um at the immediate
C captures and D6 and while this is good
it's not the best the best is Knight to
C4 and the point is that now okay
there's this tension between the Rooks
you can or you don't have to but okay
let's see the Rooks get traded off now
pawn and Bishop to F5 will put pressure
on the Knight to remove one of the
Defenders here but now Knight C captures
on D6 now he should sacrifice a piece
and after captures Knight captures
attack the queen and Bishop and after
the queen moves let's say attacking the
bishop on A3 that's undefended now
Knight B5 defense attacks while the
Knight is defended by the bishop on B5
so this is a set of moves that you have
to find if you want to win the game on
the spot and this is a you know one line
to rule them all uh but C captures and
D6 was played which is still still good
but but a bit suboptimal uh because now
after Bishop to F5 okay what do you play
here her idea is to remove the defender
of the F2 square and just play Queen
captures on F2 now comes Pawn to F3 and
Bishop captures on e4 okay obviously you
have to capture with the Rook now comes
Knight to
F5 and uh look at these knights in front
of the white king look at the the bishop
with the possibility of entering maybe
the E3 uh if the Rooks lose control of
that square the Knight also attacking D6
what do you play here uh well uh there
is an argument that maybe it would be
best to advance this Pawn all the way to
D7 but he goes for Knight to C4 now and
this is now uh well much much worse than
if the Knight come to C4 in the position
that we discussed uh here also uh a fun
fun idea would be Pawn to G4 and she's
kind of baiting this with with this
Knight to F5 move and it's even the sort
of the strongest move by white let's say
Pawn to G4 attacks the Knight what's the
idea the idea is Knight captures on D6
to attack the rook and now after Rook
captures on E5 opening up the diagonal
plus also the Knight on H5 is still
hanging now Rook 8 to B8 attacking this
bishop and once this gets defended now
you move the Knight so okay you don't
lose the Knight for nothing Knight to C6
you attack The Rook here and after a
trade here for example captures and
captures you will move the Rook to E8
and okay the game continues but um you
know you didn't really gain all that
much uh so instead he played Knight to
C4 and now comes Rook captures on A3 uh
and now Bishop captures on A3 and this
bishop captures on A3 did not come
lightly now here you have to uh decide
do you do play D7 do you play Bishop
captures on A3 do you just go Knight
captures on E5 as it does come with an
attack on The Queen Is it a free Tempo
uh the problem is uh Knight captures on
E5 can be played in so many different
ways look at this queen G7 uh and now
Pawn to D7 okay you have a defended pass
Pawn on D7 but now look at this Knight
D6 attacks The Rook uh and now after
Knight to C4 with the idea of
eliminating the Knight while defending
the bishop as the black queen on G7 is
attacked Elena could sacrifice the queen
queen captures some B2 Knight captures
and Knight captures on e4 and
considering alinaa style this is
probably what would happen captures on
e4 and now even Knight to F6 where you
will pick up this pawn and okay you have
two Rooks for the queen in a very very
tricky position uh White does have this
you know future possibility of E4 E6 but
it's still incredibly complicated and uh
Mustafa was much lower on time than Nina
uh he was already be below the 10minute
mark and uh if you try for example
defending the pawn you you just get
destroyed right away just Bishop to E3
with check and once the king moves
Knight captures on E four and there's no
defending this position so it's very
easy to misplay this with white so
Bishop captures on A3 does seem to be
the way to go if you don't want to you
know over calculate in a in a Time
scramble C captures on D6 and now we
have Queen to A4 activating the queen uh
you could also you know capture on D6
it's uh possible but it would lose you
the game look at this if Knight captures
an uh then Queen to A7 check picks up
the bishop and if the bishop captures D6
then you have this very interesting
Queen A7 check King to H1 and now Knight
capture Knight to G3 with check you
sacrifice one Knight so the other Knight
delivers check and once King H2 now
Knight captures an E4 F captures and
queen F2 with an Unstoppable Checkmate
so that's the problem so that's why you
cannot uh go after the D6 pawn queen to
A4 was played uh and now comes Knight to
F6 uh we have Rook Rook back to E1 uh
now Queen C captures on D5 and King to
H1 we have Queen to D4 going after that
F2 square and now Queen to B3
threatening some very nasty discoveries
here so King to h8 and now uh this move
uh although it's only move 33 must I
played it with four minutes less than
four minutes on the clock he played
Knight captur on D6 uh you should have
played Bishop captur on D6 and Elena's
position is still better but Knight
captures on D6 loses the game on the
spot however Elena missed it do you see
how how she could have won the game on
the spot it's a very very cool idea you
know while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this brilliancy and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to H4 going after the undefended Rook on
E1 with the threat of Knight to G3 check
and now if you go Rook to B1 let's say
you want to save the The Rook then
Knight to G3 with check King to D1 Queen
to D4 check the Knight is covering H1 so
you don't have a move here you have to
play Queen uh to E3 and then queen or
Bishop captures on E3 will be Checkmate
so after Queen to H4 your only move is
not to save The Rook you can play
something like Knight captures on F5
give up The Rook but then after Queen
captures on E1 again not much to be
played here Bishop is hanging you can
defend the bishop but now Bishop to E3
and that's pretty much it uh of course
not uh not Bishop to F4 or something
like that with the idea of eliminating
the defender of the F1 Square because
then Bishop captures is enough for a
draw but after Bishop T E3 there's no
defense here after Bishop captures on f8
and queen to F2 threatening Queen to G1
Checkmate uh only move is Queen captures
on E3 but black has too much for uh too
much material this is not uh playable so
after Knight captures on D6 Elena took
back Knight captures on D6 and now he
spotted the idea as The Rook here is
hanging uh Rook to D1 now he wants to
win back material of course the Knight
here but he missed one very tricky move
and that is Bishop to D2 which still
okay Alena is up a piece for the moment
but it still doesn't uh mean anything uh
if he plays it correctly but again in
time trouble he missed Queen to D3 Queen
to D3 with the idea uh okay you I I
either win the bishop or Knight F to E4
is played which is the strongest move
going for Knight to F2 check and if Pawn
captures then there are ideas of uh uh
well if if the Knight is captured then
what do you play Knight captures on e4
and after Queen captures on D4 e
captures on D4 okay it can be played
Bishop captures on f8 now Knight to F2
check will pick up the Rook on D1 but
it's pretty similar in all the other
lines like if Knight F to E4 and queen
captures on D4 first he will play
captures then captures then the other
Knight captures again going for Knight
to F2 check while defending the bishop
here and after Bishop captures and f8
you will uh capture The Rook on D1 and
okay alen is up a pawn but all in all it
should be a draw however after Bishop to
D2 Bishop to D3 was played uh with the
idea of just capturing the bishop now uh
but she throws in Pawn to E4 and now
there's just no way to get out of this
uh you know uh undamaged Rook captures
on D2 was played e Capt on D3 now now
she's up a piece and also has this uh
Pawn on D3 so you have to do something
Rook captures on D3 was played again
looks great as the Knight might hang but
there's Queen to F2 uh the problem of
the back rank prevents uh Mustafa from
capturing the piece on D6 so he has to
defend Rook to D1 now Rook to E8 going
again after Checkmate Queen to E1 or
Rook to E1 will be just Checkmate so
Queen to C3 stopping that while
attacking the Knight on F6 but now Rook
to E6 beautiful defensive move uh
defending this Knight and this Knight
and even though this Knight is attacked
twice Remember The Rook from D1 cannot
move due to Checkmate so he has to waste
to move playing H3 and that's all the
time Elina needs to keep her extra piece
knight to E8 and now everything is
defended elen is up a piece um Mustafa
is up a pawn but you know a piece is
stronger than a pawn so now it's time
for Alena to prove that she can win this
uh you know being up a piece Queen to C5
was played he even offers a queen trade
right away uh and she accepts it's hard
to say why you would offer a queen trade
in such a position of course it's much
better for for Elena whatever you play
it just feels like with the open King
maybe it would be a little bit better to
uh you know do it with with Queens on
the board uh but okay Queen to C5 was
played we have captur captur King to G8
and now Queen to D2 I think he realized
that uh uh Elena is not one to be rifled
with you know on an open board that she
she is very deadly when it's time to
calculate uh queen king to F7 Rook to A2
I guess you figur that you know if he
has chances of drawing this they they
lie in the end game you know maybe in a
long grueling end game G5 we have King
H2 King G6 G4 now uh sort of stopping
the black king from advancing Knight to
D5 Bishop to F2 Rook to F6 and now Rook
to A3 this is objectively completely
winning unless Alena really messes
something up rook to C6 a H4 Rook to C2
King G1 just defending the bishop uh H6
and now Rook to A6 with check Knight E2
F6 and now even Rook to A7 cutting off
the king here and now if he can get H5
check in he will win material the only
move will be Knight capts so of course
Elina blocks The Rook now H5 can be
played uh it doesn't do anything though
like if H5 checking goes back you can
even attack the Knight as it's pinned
but the other Knight will come to his
defense not a problem so Rook to a 5 was
played putting some pressure on this
Pawn here but just Knight F to D5 H
captures and G5 H captures and now Rook
to C5 offering even a rook trade with
have uh Rook to D D2 you could capture
on C5 but then uh a draw is Almost sure
so the Rooks need to remain on the board
Rook to D2 Rook to A5 and now Rook to D3
going after the Pawn King G2 now Knight
to F4 with check King to G3 and now Rook
to D2 making it hard for the for the
white king to to go anywhere if the
bishop moves uh Rook to G2 will be
Checkmate so Rook to A1 was played
Knight C to E6 we have Rook to A6 and
King to F6 Rook to B6 preventing the
king from entering the game now Rook A2
we have Bishop to D4 with check King to
E7 now Rook B7 check King D6 Rook to B6
check King D5 uh and Rook back to B2
offering a rook trade but now Rook to A3
uh Bishop back to F6 going after the G 5
pawn and Knight to D4 uh saying okay you
can have your G5 Pawn uh but if Bishop
captures on G5 then Rook captures on F3
and the Knight is nicely defended here
because uh if you um uh um after Rook
captures on F3 the the white king is in
check you have to move it and then uh
you just get checkmated if you go to H4
then Rook to H3 is checkm if you go to
H2 then The Rook continues checking uh a
rook to H3 checking has the move and now
of course the knights can move but after
Knight to D4 Bishop captures and D4 was
played it is the most precise way to do
it King captures now Rook to B5 again
going after that G5 Pawn if he can
eliminate that the two connected pass
pawns might be able to rival a knight
but of course she has no uh reason uh
you know to to allow that Rook D5 Rook
B7 uh Rook to A5 Rook to B7 now Knight
to F4 again going for that wonderful
Checkmate Rook A2 followed by Rook to G2
checkmate so Rook to G8 was played and
now Rook to E5 uh for the moment if you
go Rook to A2 then Rook capur on G5 and
that's a problem so you can't move the
Rook as long as the G5 Pawn is attacked
so Rook to E5 now comes Rook to d8 with
check King to E3 and now Rook back to A8
now you don't have a way of getting the
Rook to E2 King to E2 now comes Rook A2
check King to F1 and Rook to A1 with
check Rook to E1 uh this is how Alena
infiltrates The Possession Rook A5 and
now Knight to E2 with check King H2 and
King to F2 uh allowing the capture of
the of the G5 Pawn but it doesn't really
matter if the Rook captures on G5 then
Knight G3 with an Unstoppable Checkmate
on H1 so instead after King F2 F4 was
played but now G captures on F4 G5 he
does create a pass Pawn uh but Alena
just goes Rook to G1 King H3 we have
Pawn to F3 King to H4 and now Knight to
F4 Rook to A2 check we have King to E3
and now Pawn to G6 uh and now Knight
captures on G6 even if she captures with
the Rook um uh there's no uh there's no
way for um uh for her to actually
stalemate uh the white king because even
if if you go Rook uh here check then
King captures it's not uh King will not
capture it's not going to be stalemate
uh for those of you who are wondering
why uh the king cannot go anywhere so if
it's if the Rook Spears and it's White's
move it's a draw it's stalemate but if
Rook checks here then the Knight Will
capture if you go Rook A3 check you will
not have a chance to sacrifice The Rook
because the Knight will just block and
as soon as the Knight moves you do have
access to these squares so okay you
could capture it with either doesn't
really matter King to H3 and now Knight
to F4 with check King to H4 and Knight
to D3 Rook to A8 and now Pawn to F2
preparing to advance the pawn to a queen
Rook E8 check Knight to E5 um or No it
didn't didn't even uh come to this point
uh let me just check at which point the
the game ended uh I don't want to trick
you guys uh yeah it ended with this
Knight to D3 move yeah it was in this
position un move 85 that Mustafa must
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here I just wanted to
show you why well if if the Rook moves
okay you can deliver some checks but uh
you can even play this beautiful tricky
Knight to E5 move you can sacrifice the
Knight and after King F4 uh you don't
even have the promote the pawn to a
queen because Rook to H1 will now be
Checkmate or you know you move the king
and then you allow the capture of the of
the Rook on
E5 uh so brilliant brilliant game by by
Alina just showing that she can you know
out calculate anyone as I mean look at
Mustafa over 300 rating points over
alinaa but doesn't mean anything as she
did defeat Hans Neiman in the previous
round yeah and these were only some of
the lines like each of these positions
could be analyzed in in so many branches
because there are so many tricky moves
but you know it'd be it'd be too long a
video if I covered all of that so
hopefully you know I covered the the
interesting ones and that you guys were
able to feel the intensity and the
complexity of this game uh so yeah very
nicely done Elina uh taking down two
very strong Grand Masters to two games
in a row we'll see how she does in the
next round uh I would like to thank
Brian pwin Johan CL Len Herbert yunong
and Christopher and Ruth Burkett for a
contribution to my Channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I just
realized that it's 2m. Central European
Time so the next round just started see
you soon